ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen viele
kennen die Söldner der russischen
wagnergruppe vor allem aus der Ukraine
sie sind aber auch weltweit im Einsatz
nicht nur dort sondern zum Beispiel auch
im Sudan wo zuletzt die Kämpfe so
eskaliert sind dass ein Krieg dort
befürchtet wird wir sprechen heute
darüber welche Macht die wagnergruppe
hat wo sie im Einsatz ist und was sie
überhaupt macht Jan Schüssler fast
zusammen
viele Aktivitäten der wagnergruppe in
der Ukraine sind bekannt vor allem die
Kämpfe um bachmut bestimmen die Söldner
auf russischer Seite seit Monaten im
Fokus dabei oft ein Mann jetzt gehen die
brigoschin er ist das Aushängeschild der
Wagner Söldner und gilt öffentlich als
ihr Chef die Aktivitäten von Wagner und
weiteren söldnergruppen gehen allerdings
weit über die Ukraine hinaus in bis zu
30 Ländern werden Operationen vermutet
vor allem in Afrika ist der Einfluss
privater russischer Militärfirmen belegt
in Mali sollen beispielsweise etwa 800
Wagner Söldner für die malische
Übergangsregierung kämpfen auch
außerhalb Afrikas in Syrien war der
Einfluss deutlich dort unterstützten
wagnereinheiten die Truppen von
Machthaber Assad die Ziele und der
Einfluss der Militärfirmen sind
vielfältig sie bieten dem Kreml ein
Instrument den russischen Einfluss
weltweit auszudehnen häufig werden
Söldner aus dem russischen Militär und
den Sicherheitskräften rekrutiert sie
bauen dann Netzwerke in wichtigen
Einsatzgebieten auf zudem werden
militärische Stützpunkte errichtet
Wagner und Co sind aber nicht nur
seltener mit ihnen verbunden sind
verschiedene Firmen diese bieten Moskau
die Möglichkeit den wirtschaftlichen
Einfluss in Entwicklungsländern
auszuweiten etwa mit Goldminen
Beobachter sehen den Ursprung dieser
privaten Militärfirmen im Jahr 2006
damals kündigte Wladimir Putin vor der
Duma Änderungen im militärischen
Führungssystem Russlands
tja also das ist einer der möglichen
Gründe wie es damals begann und wir
schauen jetzt darauf was Wagner heute
weltweit macht wir haben es gerade
gesehen wollen uns aber noch mal einen
Überblick verschaffen um auch die
Dimension klar zu machen wie groß der
Einfluss der Wagner Söldner
möglicherweise ist wir schauen noch mal
auf die Weltkarte und sehen dort
verschiedene Gebiete aus Russland
herausgesteuert wie gesagt und dann geht
es hinaus quasi in die ganze Welt wir
sehen wenn wir mal in Asien und Südasien
anfangen Gebiete wie Sri Lanka und
Indonesien Syrien oder Irak haben wir
gerade gesehen vereinzelt in Europa und
Südamerika und vor allem aber in Afrika
und dort wollen wir jetzt hingehen und
mit unserer Korrespondentin sprechen und
zwar im Sudan goldene atai ist vor Ort
in Kairo in unserem Studio in Ägypten
und hat dort die Konflikte im Blick die
sich in den letzten Wochen zugespitzt
haben goldene so sehr dass
un-generalsekretärisch befürchtet der
Konflikt könne sich in einen Krieg
verwandeln der die Region über Jahre
beeinflussen könnte was weiß man welche
Rolle die Wagner Söldner dort spielen
also
wagner-chefregozin hat in den
vergangenen Tagen immer wieder die
Präsenz seiner Firma die Präsenz seiner
Gruppen dort im Sudan negiert aber das
erscheint zunehmend fragwürdig den
US-Journalisten haben unter Berufung auf
festliche Sicherheitskreise berichtet
das ist verstärkte Aktivitäten gibt die
man gut beobachten kann entlang der
Grenze zwischen der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik zwischen Libyen und dem Sudan
Wagner hat ja in der Vergangenheit einer
Seite in diesem Sudan Krieg den
Paramilitärs immer wieder Unterstützung
angeboten in Form von Munition in Form
von Fahrzeugen und das hat diese auch
trainiert und jetzt gibt es offenbar
Anzeichen dass noch mehr angeboten wurde
nämlich Gewehre und tragbare
luftverteidigungseinheiten und diese
Bodenluft Raketen die hätten tatsächlich
den sudanesischen Paramilitärs in ihrem
Kampf gegen die Armee auch eine
auch sehr erheblich geholfen
darüber hinaus aber gibt es keine
Anzeichen dass es jetzt besonders innige
Beziehungen gibt zwischen dem Chef der
sudanesischen Paramilitärs dem General
hermeti und Moskau
goldene welche Ziele verfolgt denn die
russische Regierung im Sudan
das sind insgesamt drei Ziele zum einen
sind es finanzielle Ziele am es geht
darum Präsenz zu zeigen vor Ort vor
allen Dingen nach 2014 als Russland nach
der Invasion der Krim mit Sanktionen
belegt wurde hat man sich umgeschaut und
das Interesse an Afrika ist vor allen
Dingen in neu entfacht und Russland das
Interesse vor allen Dingen an
afrikanischen Bodenschätzen und wir
haben gerade auch über das Gold das
afrikanische Gold etwas erfahren Sudan
ist das Land mit den drittgrößten
Goldreserven und die Firma von Wagner
Chef jetzt gehen die Gregorian ist dort
in Goldminen beteiligt die Parallelität
die es logistisch unterstützt und
ausbildet die fungieren dort als
Sicherheitsdienst
es geht aber darüber hinaus auch um
geopolitische Ziele es geht auch darum
dass Russland wirklich Interesse hat
seine Präsenz am Roten Meer auszubauen
das geht um den Aufbau einer Marinebasis
man will gemeinsam mit den Sudanesen
dort einen Hafen ausbauen die
Verhandlungen dazu sind noch nicht
abgeschlossen aber es geht großen vor
allen Dingen darum den
us-sicherheitsinteressen im Roten Meer
entgegenzuwirken und dann gibt es
insgesamt politische Ziele im Sudan und
da muss man so ein bisschen das
russische Verhalten etwas nurancierter
betrachten das ist kein
schwarz-weiß-spiel sondern insgesamt ist
das für Russland so dass es beide Seiten
in diesem Krieg in diesem aktuellen
Krieg unterstützt sowohl die Armee als
auch die Paramilitärs insgesamt geht es
Russland darum dass im Sudan ein
Übergang zur Demokratie verhindert wird
denn dieser Übergang zur Demokratie
könnte eben seinen Interessen im Sudan
schaden
nun nimmt die wagnergruppe ja auch
Einfluss auf andere afrikanische Länder
haben wir gesehen zum Beispiel im Chart
welchen welche welchen Einfluss nimmt
sie da
ja Russlands Außenminister hat ja vor
einigen Tagen sehr offensiv betont dass
legitime afrikanische Regierungen ein
Recht haben auf die Dienste der
wagnergruppe zurückzugreifen
wir haben vor einigen Tagen vor einigen
Wochen auch gesehen das hat immer mehr
US-Geheimdienst leaks gegeben und einige
dieser liest die haben tatsächlich die
Rolle Russlands in Afrika thematisiert
unter anderem auch die Rolle Russlands
im Chat das ist ein ganz interessantes
Beispiel denn der Chat ist ein ganz
zentraler Verbündeter der USA im Kampf
gegen den islamistischen Extremismus und
da gibt es wenn man diesen
US-Geheimdienst liegt glauben will
tatsächlich Bemühungen Russlands
schottische Rebellen in die
Zentralafrikanische Republik zu locken
und dort auszubilden für einen
Staatsstreich im Chat der natürlich
US-Interessen dort entgegen steht also
hier handelt es sich um weitaus mehr
offenbar als im sudanes handelt sich um
richtige
destabilisierungsversuche so sagen es
zumindest diese amerikanischen Quellen
und das soll sogar so weit gehen dass
jewgeni-pricotin eben eine sogenannte
Konföderation afrikanischer Staaten
anstrebt eine prorussische
anti-westliche Konföderation
verschiedene afrikanischer Staaten die
die gesamte Breite des afrikanischen
Kontinents umfassen soll
vielen Dank Kollegen für diese
Einschätzungen und Hintergründe aus
Kairo danke schön dass du mit bei uns im
Stream warst und wir gehen weiter von
dem einen Konflikt oder von vielen
Konflikten die dort auf dem Kontinent
sind zudem Konflikt der hier in Europa
alles dominiert nämlich der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine wir
haben es gesagt auch dort sind die
seltener von Wagner im Einsatz und wir
schalten zu unserem Reporter vor Ort
daran Hassan Sade ist uns zugeschaltet
und dabei jetzt muss ich noch mal genau
nachgucken wo du bist im Südwesten des
Landes in Wilko wo am Donau Delta bist
du derzeit du bist aber wahnsinnig viel
im Land unterwegs der ZDF was auch viel
im Osten und sehr nah auch an den
Frontlinien welche Informationen hast du
über die Wagner
[Musik]
ja ich war vier Wochen jetzt in der
Ukraine unterwegs und davon eine lange
Zeit im Osten ich war in der Nähe von
bachmund den Konstantin liefka ich habe
dort mit vielen Soldaten gesprochen und
deren Perspektive auf die Wagner Söldner
ist relativ indifferent ein Soldat hat
mir relativ einleuchtend erklärt was ist
das für ein Unterschied die russischen
Soldaten kommen um uns zu töten und das
tun die Wagner Söldner auch also für sie
ist der Unterschied nicht so groß
manche haben erzählt dass sie schon den
Eindruck hatten dass gerade jetzt in den
letzten Wochen viele
Soldaten dort waren die nicht sonderlich
kampferprobt war das mag wohl mit dieser
Rekrutierung in Russland Zusammenhängen
Mörder und Schwerverbrecher an die Front
zu bringen das sind auch etliche gerade
bei den Wagner Truppen gelandet ich weiß
aber auch von anderen Quellen dass die
wagnergruppe schon immer auch sehr gut
ausgebildet der Söldner russisch stämmig
oder Russen selber akquiriert hat und
die dort wirklich auch starke
Kampfeinheiten bilden die gerade auch in
bachmut eingesetzt worden dort hat sich
der brigochien wahrscheinlich einen
schnellen Erfolg
gewünscht und erhofft und er dachte dass
er da als in Konkurrenz zur russischen
Armee auftreten kann im Moment sind dort
vor allem Wichtigkeiten zu hören über
Beschwerden über Waffenlieferungen und
Munition und ich glaube es geht jetzt
eher darum dass man den schwarzen Peter
weiter schiebt wäre für die nicht
erfolgreiche Offensive auf bachmut zu
verantwortlich ist da ich gucke gerade
mal in die Kommentare und da gibt's
einige auch zur Ukraine und zu den
seltenen unter Ukraine einer auf YouTube
User schreibt z.B da die eigene Armee
nichts taugt braucht man seltener selbst
in der Ukraine mit Hinblick auf die
russische Armee und das passt so ein
bisschen zu dem was du gerade gesagt
hast eine Frage noch doch die
US-Geheimdienste melden jetzt dass seit
Dezember mehr als 20.000 Soldaten in der
Ukraine getötet und 80.000 verwundet
worden sein und bei der Hälfte etwa der
gefangenen Soldaten auf russischer Seite
handle es sich um Söldner der
wagnergruppe was sagt das über deren
Qualifikationen aus Elitegruppe
Elitetruppe hört sich anders an
so wie ich gesagt habe es gibt
wahrscheinlich zwei Sparten innerhalb
dieser wagner-gruppe es ist allerdings
auch schwer von der ukrainischen Seite
aus zu beobachten wie diese Gruppe sich
im Kampf vor mir hat genauere Einblicke
habe ich da nicht aber der Rückschluss
ist sicherlich richtig dass allein das
rekrutiert werden musste im Gefängnis
sagt eigentlich schon alles aus das ist
ähm militärisch eine bankrotte Erklärung
aber noch noch viel mehr moralisch und
so sieht eigentlich auch die
Zivilbevölkerung die wagnergruppen hier
es ist ein weiterer Beweis für den
moralischen Zerfall von Russland
vielen Dank Sarah Hassan sa die in die
Ukraine für diese Einschätzungen die du
dort direkt vor Ort machen konntest und
erfahren konntest danke schön daran
und wir sehen hier weiter im Stream
viele Fragen die sich vor allem auf die
Einsätze von Wagner beziehen die Fragen
welche Waffen Wagner einsetzt welche
Spezialgebiete sie sozusagen
in ihren Diensten haben und diese ganzen
Fragen können wir mit einem experten
klären nämlich den
Politikwissenschaftler Severin Player
vom Think Tank der Bundeswehr in Hamburg
schön guten Abend Herr Player schönen
guten Abend ich muss jetzt mal sortieren
denn es gibt so ganz viele Fragen
tatsächlich die sich damit beschäftigen
was die wagnergruppe kann ich fange mal
an mit also kann in Anführungszeichen
wenn man das positiv sieht im Sinne
dessen dass es gut ist was sie tun sind
es wenn odental fragt über facebook ist
die seltener Gruppe Wagner nur erprobt
in der Verwendung klassischer
Kriegswaffen oder auch im Ste von
Drohnen die Frage stellt sich heute
besonders nach dem Drohnenangriff auf
den Kreml
also das ist zumindest auch deine schon
mal eine gute Frage denn die Gruppe
Wagner hat sich ja auch geändert oder
das sagt ja nicht nur die Gruppe Wagner
sondern auch die gesamten anderen
sollten auf Firmen die Gruppe Wagner ist
nur die prominenteste Variante davon zu
den Waffen ist zu sagen mittlerweile
benutzen sie auch Drohnen ja
gibt auch gezielte oder dezidierte
drohneneinheiten die diese Aufgabe
wahrnehmen und darüber hinaus gibt es
eben jetzt auch gepanzerte Einheiten die
ganz klassische operationsarten also das
ganz klassische angreifen bzw auch das
Verteidigen wahrnehmen wie eben das
russische Militär auch das einzige wohl
worauf sie nicht zurückgreifen ist eine
unabhängige Luftwaffe
es gibt auch Fragen zu anderen Gruppen
und zwar fragt ein User über Youtube
haben Sie Informationen zu den
gazpromsöldnern und anderen neuen
Gruppen die scheinen ja auch eine große
Rolle zu spielen können Sie dazu was
sagen
ja also die große Grundproblematik
aktuell ist dass die Gruppe Wagner alles
überdeckt wenn wir in der Debatte um die
Söldnerfirmen in Russland sprechen
eigentlich der große
Zwist in Russland ist aktuell zwischen
dem Verteidigungsminister scheuu und dem
Gruppe Wagner Chef ähm
brigoche beide haben sollten Firmen
brigoschen in die Gruppe Wagner und
scheuko eben die Gruppe Patriot die
Gruppe Patriot zum Beispiel ist
rekrutiert sich hauptsächlich auf
Spezialkräften und wird eben auch
dezidiert von dem Verteidigungsminister
der unterstützt
aktuelle Analysen besagen z.B auch dass
beide Gruppen gegeneinander sich
ausspielen und auch gerade das auftre
von prigoshin zeugt davon dass die
Russische Föderation auch an internen
Machtkampf sozusagen auch widerspiegelt
das heißt es nicht dass es Präsident
Putin betrifft sondern eher seine
Gefolgsleute denn
brigoschin und scheugu haben eine
jahrelange Feindschaft die sie jetzt
anscheinend auch in der Ukraine mit
ihren Söldnertruppen indirekt ausfechten
wenn man so möchte deswegen die ganzen
Gruppierungen werden indirekt auch
normalerweise von anderen
Firmenchefs auch mitfinanziert
Gazprom ist da ein also ein kleiner Teil
davon die in Bataillon Stärke sozusagen
was rekrutieren das heißt das sind
meistens Spezialisten die bei der
Verteidigung eingesetzt werden aber
meistens nicht nur Ukraine sondern eben
in Afrika oder auch auf Öl Bohrstation
vor vor der Küste Afrikas zum Beispiel
ganz also ganz problematisch ist eben
die Sache mit der Zuordnung wer ist was
denn genau das ist das Ziel der
Russischen Föderation in diesem Umfang
dass man nicht genau weiß wer was und
wann macht und diese nicht zuweisbarkeit
ist eben genau das Ziel
ja der Söldner Firmen wenn man die so
nennen möchte dazu gibt es ein Gedanken
eines Youtube Users mit dem schönen
Namen Hip Hop Guru der schreibt solche
separaten Armeen innerhalb eines Staates
sind für den Staat immer ein Balanceakt
denn wenn sie zu stark werden dann
können Sie sehr schnell die eigene Macht
gefährden das geht so ein bisschen in
die Richtung dessen was sie gerade
gesagt haben zielt aber natürlich vor
allem auch auf die Frage wie gefährlich
können diese Armeen in der Armee für
Putin werden
also aktuell kann man sagen dass es
nicht darum geht dass die Putin
gefährden viel spannender ist ja die
Frage was die Machtkämpfe im in der
Administration
dazu sagen man kann eben auch
Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen wie manche
dieser
Akteure die Zukunft innerhalb Russlands
sehen nämlich dass man eigene
Streitkräfte braucht um notfalls seine
eigenen Freunde in Sicherheit zu
bekommen und der Verteidigungsminister
scheuburg mit der Gruppe Patriot hat
dahingehend einer der größten Streit
machte innerhalb Russlands und eben auch
am besten ausgebildet das heißt
wenn man jetzt mal Blick in die Zukunft
wagen möchte kann es eben sein dass die
Russische Föderation intern schon plant
wie es weitergehen könnte sollte eine
Niederlage eintreten natürlich ist es
jetzt ein bisschen ins Blaue hinein aber
es ist sehr bezeichnend dass sehr viele
Oligarchen und auch sehr viele hohe
Politiker eben private Söldner bzw semi
Streitkräfte in Anführungsstrichen
anheuern um eben sich in der Ukraine zu
beteiligen oder eben auch ihre Freunde
direkt zu schützen
dann lassen Sie uns mal ein bisschen
darauf schauen wer die Menschen sind die
da kämpfen oder in die Kämpfe geschickt
werden hier fragt ein User welche
Nationalitäten haben die Mitglieder der
Gruppe Wagner und können Sie darüber
vielleicht ein bisschen hinausgehen auch
und die Frage beantworten welche welche
Männer in der Regel nehme ich an sind
das
die Gruppe Wagner oder auch die anderen
Söldnerfirmen haben angefangen mit den
Spezialkräften der den sogenannten ksso
das sind praktisch die äquivalente zu
den Navy Seals in den USA die eben
sobald sie ausgeschieden sind ein Beruf
eben gesucht haben und den haben sie
dort auch gefunden die Grundproblematik
ist dass am Anfang als die letzten 15
Jahre das einigermaßen gut funktioniert
hatte dieses Modell denn er inzwischen
Afrika sind die meisten Militäreinheiten
schlecht ausgebildet und somit kann man
auch eine gute ausgebildeten Soldaten in
auch einen kleinen geringer Anzahl da
relativ schnell Erfolge erzielen die
Grundproblematik fängt aber an sobald
eben ein großer Konflikt wie eine
Ukraine ansteht dann muss ich auch
andere Leute rekrutieren die eben nicht
diesen Spezialkräfte Hintergrund haben
denn so viele gibt es dort nicht und
bezüglich der Nationalitäten kann man
eben sagen das ist der bunte Mix ist äh
den Russische Föderation auch bisher
angebracht hat momentan ist aber so so
dass hauptsächlich die Leute rekrutiert
werden die relativ weit weg von Moskau
bzw auch St Petersburg sind das ist
eigentlich so der klassische Ansatz um
eben auch Verluste auf die gesamte
Russische Föderation verteilen zu können
der Vorteil aber wenn man eben diese
Leute rekrutiert ist auch dass man eben
keine Hinterbliebenen Versorgung
gewährleisten muss wie zum Beispiel bei
normalen Wehrpflichtigen oder normalen
russischen föderationssoldaten
nun ist die Gruppe ja auch für ihre
besondere Brutalität bekannt was weiß
man denn über die Führung dieser Söldner
Gruppen über das Menschenbild das
dahinter steht über die Art der Führung
über über Militär
Regeln die dort gelernt oder vielleicht
auch bewusst missachtet werden
also man muss einfach sagen dass diese
Gruppierungen keinerlei Rechtsprechung
unterliegen es gab ja die Fälle in
Syrien wo eben auf grausamster Art und
Weise Menschen misshandelt worden sind
bzw auch gegnerisches Soldaten einfach
massakriert worden sind die haben zwar
in der Russischen Föderation für einen
kurzen Aufschrei gesorgt aber richtig
vorgegangen gegen diese Leute ist man
nicht denn die wurden einfach nur
versetzt intern in der Gruppe Wagner
oder eben in der in der Gruppe patrio
z.B die Frage die sie raus ergibt ist
eigentlich was der rechts Charakter
generell ist denn grundsätzlich sind
diese Firmen eigentlich in Russland
verboten seit 2016
meistens ihren Hauptsitz haben ihren
Firmenhauptsitz und eben von dort aus
ähm auch ihre finanziellen Ströme aus
agieren
weitergehend ist halt auch noch mal zu
verstehen dass diese Gruppierungen eben
keine klassischen Söldnerfirmen im
eigentlichen Sinne sind sondern
eigentlich semi staatliche Akteure das
heißt sie sind vom Staat geduldet und
werden auf dem Start finanziert also sie
generieren keine Gewinne per se um sich
damit neue Ausrüstung oder ihre Leute zu
bezahlen sondern sie generieren Gewinne
für die Russische Föderation selbst das
heißt dir die Begrifflichkeit Söldner
ist da auch ein bisschen zu kurz gefasst
ich hatte eine Frage die anschließt an
das was goldene atai gerade aus Afrika
auch gesagt hat die Frage war von einem
User ob die wagnergruppen gefährlich
sein könnten für die Welt und das ist
jetzt zwar eine sehr global formulierte
Frage aber wenn man sich anguckt was da
in Afrika zum Beispiel passiert das ähm
versucht wird Demokratie Bewegungen zu
stoppen das Diktaturen gestärkt werden
dass man vor allem dort versucht
Gesprächspartner zu halten mit denen man
gute Geschäfte machen kann und man davon
ausgeht dass Demokratien für die Welt
und die Menschen die darin leben
grundsätzlich besser sind als Diktaturen
kommt man dann dahin zu sagen das Wagner
gefährlich ist für die Welt
grundlegend muss man eben auch wieder
sagen die Gruppe Wagner alleine ist da
nicht der gefährdende Aspekt sondern das
ist die Russische Föderation in ihrer
Art und Weise eben Einfluss auszuüben
aktuell
denn wie gesagt es gibt einige
Gruppierungen die Welt wird unterwegs
sind und man darf auch nicht vergessen
dass der russische Geheimdienst auch
weltweit operiert wir haben das ja auch
zum Beispiel auch in Berlin selbst
festgestellt bei den Mordanschlägen auch
im Tiergarten z.B das heißt diese
generelle ja
Drang sozusagen Stabilität zu
untergraben haben wir beobachten wir
schon seit 20 Jahren die Grund- oder die
die Grundannahme dass die Gruppe Wagen
da jetzt eine gesonderten
Gefährdungspotenzial hat das teile ich
nicht es ist eher eine Gefahr für
instabile Staaten in denen eben kaum ähm
ja Sicherheit herrscht und keine gut
ausgebildeten Truppen vorhanden sind die
aussehen wird die Gruppe Wagen am
meistens also wenn man sich jetzt auf
die direkt bezieht auch meistens direkt
angeworben beziehungsweise eben auch
dort entsandt um die dortige Regierung
bzw eine gewisse Gruppierung zu
unterstützen das heißt sie sind auch auf
die Unterstützung vor Ort angewiesen
also die
instabilitätsvariante halte ich auch
dahingehend ein bisschen für gewagt weil
das eben die us-protokolle sind Chat ist
aber einer der wichtigsten verbündenden
Frankreichs und Frankreich unterhält
dort eine der wichtigsten Militärbasen
außerhalb der französischen Republik das
heißt
Chat ist eigentlich eins der stabilsten
Länder was das angeht und auch wenn dort
sozusagen die Gruppe Wagen aktiv wäre
wäre dort genug um das auch abwehren zu
können wenn man aufklärt dann eine
letzte Frage noch zum Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern wir haben jetzt viel
über Russland und seine Aktivitäten und
seine seltener drucken gesprochen aber
wenn ich in die Chats gucke dann sehe
ich auch z.B das ähm ganz oft von
Frankreich und der Armee dort gesprochen
wird und das ist ja auch andere also von
der Fremdenlegion gesprochen wird
Entschuldigung und das ist das müssen
sie jetzt besser einordnen als ich
seltener Gruppen ist das eine die
Fremdenlegion ist das andere aber es
gibt ja auch andere private
internationale Militärdienstleister
sich das so schön anhört die ähnliche
Dienste in der ganzen Welt
tun können Sie das noch mal einordnen
zum Schluss das ist eben die
Schwierigkeit des Rechts Charakters denn
eigentlich haben wir mit der
mondkonvention ja eigentlich auch eine
international bindende Erklärung das
sollten auf Firmen verboten sind
diese sogenannten private military
companies umgehen dieses geschickt indem
sie Dienstleistungen Anführungsstrichen
anbieten
somit habe ich eine Firma die z.B eben
diese Sicherheit ähm von einer also von
einer erdölfel z.B gewährleistet ich
habe aber auch z.B Angebote einfach dass
ein eine PMC einfach die Küche betreibt
in einem Feldlager wie z.B auch in
Afghanistan geschehen die Frage die sich
daraus ergibt ist wo sehen wir diese
Gruppierungen überhaupt sie haben ja
gerade angesprochen die französische
Fremdenlegion die französische
fremdliche ist Teil der französischen
Armee das sind jetzt zum Beispiel die
Gruppierungen Wagen und Patriot ja nicht
und werden auch nicht eingegliedert die
haben ihre eigenen Strukturen und
agieren außerhalb der befehlsbefugnisse
der Russischen Föderation was das
bedeutet ist einfach dass ich dort eine
Vielfalt an Akteuren habe die das
kommandieren und auch die effektive
Operationsführung einfach vor Ort massiv
gefährden für die Russische Föderation
was eben auch Rückschlüsse auf die
innenpolitische Situation zulässt wenn
man sich aber PMC ist generell anguckt
ist es so dass auch westliche Staaten
natürlich
auf diese zurückgreifen weil eben ganz
viele Experten nach ihrer Zeit in der
reaktiven Dienstzeit in solche Firmen
abwandern das ist einfach liegt einfach
momentan in der Natur der Dinge
sagt der Militärexperte Severin Playa
vielen Dank dass Sie heute aus Potsdam
mit dabei in der Sendung waren
Dankeschön tschüss und vielen herzlichen
Dank auch an Sie liebe Userinnen und
User für die vielen Fragen und
Kommentare und enden möchte ich mit
einem positiven Kommentar zum Schluss
ein
Usernamens dvpilus schreibt über Youtube
glaube ich ähm danke für dieses Format
Infos kompakt und aktuell so zahle ich
gerne meine Rundfunkgebühren bitte
weiter so sehr herzlichen Dank dafür und
wir sagen tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal